hey there welcome back to Westeros
weekly the Game of Thrones Q&A show
where we're gonna pay all of your
burning little cues
we've got multiple huge questions this
week but first I'm Phil Molina with me
always Maude Garrett and of course we're
gonna get right into it with the biggest
question that we were left with after
this episode and who it's a doozy it's
huge yeah who the hell is the rightful
heir to the Iron Throne is it Daenerys
Targaryen
or is it Jon Jon Targaryen and Targaryen
you guys he's legitimate yeah sorry if
we're like freaking out a little too
much but this was one of the biggest
most important reveals in the history of
Game of Thrones and so fittingly you
know I came from the beloved most
important character in all of Westeros
really mm-hmm they gave her something
that's fun finally we have to start with
the context of this scene like what's
going on and what it means before we can
debate who actually legally has the
right to the throne which isn't even
just between the two of those two
Targaryen obviously no no so let's have
a look at some context of the scene
because it happened quite quickly I
actually had to go back and rewind and
be like wait a second
so Gilley's looking through the most
ancient books at the citadel Stan's been
tasked with copying them they're both
bored out of their mind
now she's specifically reading the diary
of the High Septon Maynard Maynard I do
not bother looking up High Septon may
nod he's not in the books this is a
result of the show normally high septons
do not take names they just go by High
Septon the high seas II no no the high
oh don't go easy with easy easy peasy
all right I didn't have names now he was
the High Septon when Robert's rebellion
was happening that's the era that we can
talk about and he was mid minute Mirren
and what about him well he was
meticulous at taking notes I mean he
counted everything and recorded it he
counted when he dropped some know there
were stems to the he counted his stuff
it carries poop and he also counted his
poops yeah thank you
he also happened to count and record
marriage annulments how convenient right
especially when Gilly wants to read out
so specifically prints rag arse not
obviously that's actually prince rhaegar
targaryen and then the show doesn't give
us the other name but regards only legal
public marriage was to Elia Martell
whose oberyn's sister so that marriage
annulment would be between the two of
them yes and then the new secret
marriage of course at the High Septon
was performing would be between Ned
Stark's sister and the woman who was
supposed to be marrying Robert Baratheon
but it didn't happen
that of course is lie on a stock so you
guys remember that last season Brandi I
ready kind of showed us this information
during that Tower of joy seen that
Lyanna stark had a baby was Rhaegar and
Ned pretended it was his and he needed
Jon Snow you guys know this yes now that
bit isn't exactly news we already knew
that that Jon secretly has Targaryen
blood in him but this episode that we
had it explains that in this scene where
he's coming true though with his touch
obviously only a Targaryen can do that
because I mean it's a dragon and any
other time dragon doesn't like a person
they're dead except one other time do
you remember the only other person that
has touched a dragon and they were okay
with it what's the big mystery about
this person potentially being a
Targaryen
Kurian Tyrion Lannister was also able to
get up real close and personal my
favorite part about this scene go Danny
sitting on the back being like are you
going to my trip are you touching my oh
you are going doing love hard eyes well
it's like when your dog likes your
potential boyfriend some important role
friend or anyone yes yeah I judge are
Martin said by the way that only
Targaryen can do that like tame a dragon
they've inherited ability through kind
of like magic in their DNA so that's why
people would always get burned up so
again that reconfirms that maybe Tyrion
is a fair game but really that John is a
Targaryen the fact that this scene
happened but of course I wasn't a big
news thing it didn't matter at all if
you are a Targaryen especially if you're
John it doesn't mean squat because he's
a bastard so it doesn't matter if he's
John Targaryen he's still a Snow which
means he's not legitimate
except okay thanks to this High Septon
Maynard's poop log uh uh he ain't a
bastard anymore yeah let's talk about
the legitimate marriage that has
happened between Rhaegar and Lyanna
which means the first time in history of
the entire Song of Ice and Fire
we're talking books and show this means
he is a legitimate Targaryen do not call
him John Snow anymore his name is John
Targaryen he just don't know it
or maybe something else again he didn't
know that either though hey you're under
Goering the second Georgia Harrisburg
area anyway it answers a really
fascinating question that I've always
had about the Tower of joy scene see
outside of John's birthplace were
Targaryen Kingsguard
now as like Sir Arthur Dayne was one of
them there was a bunch of them but
that's really weird
even Ned is like why are the Kingsguard
here shouldn't they be protecting the
Queen she has with her she's run off the
Dragonstone she has a little prince tiny
Viserys who's eventually going to be a
huge jerk off and suck and be the worst
that's a cake guys he does not and i
fantastic way though he should
technically be next in line for the
throne and that gets a little
complicated with the timeline here about
Tara goes from explain that real quick
yeah the Tower of joy happened after
Prince Rhaegar death by Robert at the
Trident and it also have been after the
mad Kings death by Jaime
stabbed in the back
so those moments happen before the Tower
of joy scene so the stairs would
potentially be the supposed king now
yeah right so what you're saying is
right here the Kings God made no sense
protecting Liana because technically the
young king was supposed to be Viserys
yes exactly right but we just found out
why that's not true and why they're
there this explains who by the way has a
legitimate claim overall in general
here's the answer to question yeah in
Westeros the claim to the throne goes
through the eldest living son of the
eldest living son of the Elvises living
so as so on so on and then when you run
out of sons or living ones you then you
can go back up the chain and try again
on a different
male heir then there are they a female
heir eventually but that's when you can
go back up alright keeps going down yes
I picture a family tree here Rhaegar was
the mad Kings first son and regards
first and only son aegon was killed by
the mountain so then the claim goes back
to the saris okay except not anymore
because Rhaegar has another living son
who is legitimately born right here
right so even though John let's call him
John Targaryen for the point of this was
born after Viserys Targaryen it does not
matter Rhaegar was next in line right so
his son John outranks regards brother
Viserys and so John outranks Viserys
then he outranks Daenerys boom okay cuz
Daenerys is also just another sibling
like Viserys but because Daenerys is the
only one left she thinks she has a
legitimate claim to the throne but
that's about the case anymore which is
why this is such a big deal and she is
not gonna like that
I kind of thought that the fact that she
was a woman shouldn't matter anymore
because you know how Cersei who really
has no legitimacy at all being the queen
of King's Landing and all the Seven
Kingdoms that gender shouldn't matter if
you know so she can be queen then so
could Danny yeah I feel like Dany has a
lot of bad news coming like she's also
about to find out that she's his aunt
and that's also gonna busy Oscar yeah
well actually to go back into the
history of the Targaryen they usually
married siblings to keep the bloodline
going coach they blood be magic with the
Dragons but if you go back into the
history of Sargeras she wasn't down with
marrying her brother so she's not into
incest but I think she might end up
being intensive anywhere hold on are we
like out mansplaining each other right
wait this is not man weakness and Flynn
is like I know he said but here's why
you're wrong I think my bad oh sorry
this means that Daenerys his claim to
the throne isn't totally illegitimate
it's not right it's almost exactly the
same argument that Stannis Baratheon had
to his claims for the throne as well
back when Robert Baratheon passed away
he was a next sibling in line but he
wasn't Robert's son yes except even he
had to state that Joffrey and Joffrey
were illegitimate in order to even make
that work like if Joffrey had been
legitimate or gender even said I might
have been legitimate then Stannis would
not have a claim at all so John's
legitimate had no one else he fought for
Cara right so my question is does Danny
want the throne enough to do the same
thing that Stannis did you know it's
you're going to say that maybe John is
illegitimate oh that's a good question I
think that's a question that you guys
should answer for especially you can
have that discussed in the comments but
also we have to acknowledge that we are
only talking about the Targaryen claim
here for the throne right yeah well
since technically Cersei would argue
that she has a legitimate claim earnest
how
maybe she's saying it's true Robert
Tommen some things but she is there and
she's not going anywhere
yeah and that's not totally worth
ignoring Circe's claim because there's
actually this awesome law professors
that I've been like tweeting with at
Louie de ray Joan
yeah that's it I've been trading to eat
with him I'm at the mo give me a fall if
you want he discussed with me the legal
perspective of who has the claim and he
said it's actually more like natural law
than hard law so basically whoever has
the best claim to the throne is the
person that's sitting on it right so
hard on that I mean it makes sense
Robert usurp the throne so you got rid
of the Targaryen line so whatever
happened in the past is totally
irrelevant and redundant because he's
got it now and there's a new succession
there for the Baratheon's have the right
to the throne which means technically
Sophie right except because if we
complicate even more if you think of
Robert as almost an impostor or thief
that's trying to steal the throne then
the card Aryans are the ones that would
still be the ones who built the throne
they created this Kingdom so one could
argue that their dynasty always has
rightful claim and I love how
complicated this game we've got is we've
got to move on to the rest of your
questions before we do that though you
always check in with the map to see
where everyone was and where everyone is
now so let's take a look at the map of
Westeros because there are moves so damn
far right but before that we have to
think
so much our sponsor for this week it's
Vikings war of clans guys it's a pretty
badass mobile game that you probably
already know about since I just found
out there are 10 million of you that are
already playing it being totally honest
I actually made myself stop playing it
because it really condensed Starcraft
addiction which I was completely
obsessed with for like 10 years since
its kind of like that game but it's on
mobile it's not really solid multiplayer
and it's way more like Game of Thrones
so yeah I was like I have work to do I
have to stop playing this but thank you
so much design for sponsoring us they
actually helped us upgrade our sound
quality you might have noticed so I
can't thank them enough download the
game with the link in the description
and you get free two hundred gold to
start with okay last doors pasted it
okay this is one of the weeks where I
feel extremely grateful that I have been
tracking this on a Mac because for the
past few weeks
everybody was packed into this same
little area it's just kind of like
beneath the neck right above Dorne
everybody was right there and then this
time everybody spreads way to hell out
and they did it super fast yeah
so just to cover real quick you know why
they did a tepid yeah that's and it does
why I love it that's why I have no
issues with the teleport I'm on Team
teleport yeah but just there in our
southwestern corner we still have our
mr. Charlie Sam though only we had to
get rid of the other Charlie part of the
board but he's headed north so I moved
him a little bit above old town we don't
technically know where he's going but
we're going to talk about that later
just a little north of him again we
still don't know where you're on is but
the last we saw him he was leading that
siege battle against Cash Lee Ross where
a grey worm is so we still have both of
them over there on the west coast on the
east coast we know that we have jaime
and cersei reunited in King's Landing
and we do have Danny down a dragon stone
but everybody else I was there pretty
much was like route not literally
everybody but our awesome fighters they
all went north dead end
yeah house no si squad so I'm probably
going to have to combine all these
sigils
pretty soon like into like some cool
badass like please
yeah magnificent seven séjour so then
except for the night king one up there
Snow White and the Seven men over the
six men John why didn't hey yeah this
takes out a guy we snow I all right yeah
why did I keep the white I don't know
but so we have the night king who we're
going to guess is now we had them a
little bit more west but we're going to
guess that he is between hardhome a nice
watch
based on the direction the crows took
and then we have the Brotherhood without
banners the free folk and then John's
new crew which is so badass we got these
guys yeah obviously uh adding Gendry to
the team is is making you squirm oh uh
yes I'm on Team Gendry I think that is
that there are no teams but you don't
have to be in team ginjury why not he's
not against like other be like like a my
country all right your team Gendry
I'm team he House Stark sure okay you
just want Gendry to take care oh yeah
okay we got Jorah teamed up there and
then John I'm purposely not much in
Davos because he himself is even like I
don't include me in the fighting stuff
but these people along with the people
who are also nearby are some of the best
fighters in Westeros period not all of
the best but a lot of the best and
that's something a lot of people forget
about the Brotherhood without banners
those people were all in town for
attorney when they got formed they were
all nice and amazing people too and then
just real quick we'll check in on
Winterfell
we still have brand Arya Littlefinger
there and also those various Lords that
are there and a lot goes on there so
let's move on to the Twitter Q & A so
every single week asked the show jump on
Twitter use the hashtag Westeros weekly
and ask your question basically we
forget the question that seems to be
getting the most traction or may have
some really interesting answers so we're
going to answer them here right on the
show with question number one coming in
from at Agnes underscore B do you think
Cersei is it bees imagine if it was bees
do you think so C is really pregnant or
is she making it up to keep Jamie on her
side manipulation and finish
I'll be watching a soap opera basically
right okay we don't know if it's a real
pregnancy or not and it's actually it's
actually a very good question I think
about it because george RR martin loved
history and sampling history and there
was a famous hysterical pregnancy of
mary the first in the 1500s uh
but that said i'm gonna guess that she
is pregnant
mostly honestly because there was a
really quick moment with her and Qyburn
and if you're listening crazy closely
when you watch that scene you'll hear
that Qyburn has just said to her he can
give her something and she's like oh
that won't be necessary so he could be
giving her something for morning
sickness or giving her something to
cause her to miscarry or something to
make her bloat to look like she's
pregnant cuz she's a liar
i I think that was like he's going to
give her a bloat mutt like gasps
something to make it look like she's
pregnant because she's a manipulating
crazy bees I don't think she would leave
all the planning of like how am I gonna
fake this pregnancy to like a second
before she's gonna see Jamie like quick
give me a bloat medicine look I do why
would they have Blut medicine
seeing me drink a beer hello oh that's
really just beer I still think that it's
going to be a very real pregnancy but
either way let's be totally clear this
baby ain't getting born right Maggie the
frogs prophecy was very specific and it
said sirs he's only gonna have three
children and she's been right about
everything else yeah so I think it's a
real pregnancy I think the baby ain't
coming though so just forget everything
that Maggie frog said sure yeah total
denial yeah okay mad denial happening
man we got another question this one's
question number two it's from at smurf
now do you think we will see your on
Inara
again this season I kind of love that we
didn't have them in this episode the
refreshing you know break from wanker
town but what do I think I reckon we are
definitely gonna see them again
I reckon are they're going to have a
huge impact in the rest of this season
and a couple of episodes that we have
first of all the reason why he's a
legitimate threat
is something that was said he references
himself as the drowned God and that is
important because during that little
roundtable session that the maesters had
they brought up a little thing with the
drowned God and we have to learn that
every bit of dialogue that these guys
say is super important or any bit of
dialogue that's getting dropped as
tidbits because hello annulment that was
blink and you miss it makes a huge thing
so why is it so important that he calls
himself the drowned God and what was it
that the maesters brought up basically
they said that the legend he promised
the drowned God would rise up and
destroy Aegon the conquerer so let's
shift whatever that was into the current
situation and let's say that you're on
claiming himself to be the drowned God
means that he'll be bringing down our
current Targaryen dinero's who knows and
in the book that was said to be a Kraken
horn and there was also a dragon horns
apparently if you blow things you can
control giant mythical creatures
good on you George are by word yeah the
Krakens apparently were real though
we're supposed to be seen in the
southern seas below dawn but I'm
thinking is he holding on to Yara
because like the Lightbringer again a
prophecy it needs a strong sacrifice to
bring something to life and it is full
power hear me out
I'm thinking he next is nice Yara and
then he claims the drowned God abilities
and can summon a Kraken it can happen
don't do this this is a big thing we
could be getting on this could happen
that's that's my thing you think I'm
like it is a judgement this is all that
you hear you're watching happening I
dragon coming in here and it's a
dragon's essence a Kraken if this
happens I'm gonna I'm gonna literally
explode like I live on the internet I'm
gonna freakin lose my [ __ ] if that
happened
sure I would love to bet that radio like
it will but I would love that
anyway the fact that he's saying drowned
God could be a big deal
he could die soon we don't know we've
got another question this one coming in
from at Jody one underscore Kenobi
amazing Twitter handle please explain
the scroll I'm not that conniving so I
guy the significance or the plan Jody
you're so sweet
you're not that conniving I totally am
so I totally get what's going on with
this oh so dramatic scroll from inside
little fingers creepy little mattress
hole yep oh I actually initially thought
that it was like the kind of holder like
a teenager has to hide from his parents
oh yeah
but Eric reminded me it's for a less
gross reason he gets to do all of that
in the break down but actually speaking
of the breakdown we're going to borrow
my favorite section from those and we're
going to pull a zoom in enhance there we
go all right so here's what the scroll
says Rob Robby Robin look I write to you
with a heavy heart our good King Robert
is dead
killed from wounds he took in a boar
hunt fathers been charged with treason
he conspired with Roberts brother's
against my beloved Joffrey my beloved
yeah and tried to steal his throne the
Lannisters are treating me very well um
from my view was every comfort I beg you
come to King's Landing landing swear
fealty to King Joffrey prevent any
strife between the great houses of
Lannister and Stark your faithful sister
Sansa so where did this obvious BS
letter come from this was the letter
that Cersei made Sansa right and center
Robb it was kind of like an early
version of the old Ben Denis letter that
keeps getting sent out now it's all the
rage this was before that Littlefinger
knows about this letter because you can
see right here I'm creeping in the
background again right there like he
always is have you been paying attention
to the little finger moments of season
by the way he keeps watching things from
a distance like as the stark children
are reunited he's got all the shots
where he's like watching and creeping on
him uh but that's because he's trying to
like study what's going on when they're
reunited and he's doing a really good
job of reading their minds a little bit
and like identifying the weaknesses and
he knows that aria thinks that Sansa
wants the throne for herself facing it
right now
you can't stop things right exactly and
Littlefinger knows that she's thinking
that so he's able to play a game of
divide and conquer
Littlefinger can create like a wedge
between Sansa and Arya and then his
power over them would be stronger while
their own connections are weaker what's
really interesting is that it does look
like Arya somehow is going to fall for
it at least for a little bit which is
like come on re like brilliant advice
that that Arya was overtly ignoring when
she was training pod I Brienne was like
don't go where your enemy leads you and
are is exactly going where their enemies
leading her because she was coming over
there joke that she says debris and
instead but I I still think that the
little finger is leading Arya right now
to this letter yet I don't think he's
going to be successful like I don't so
much has happened since that particular
time in the letter as well that it's so
irrelevant right well they'll be able to
like unravel it really quickly but also
remember the the trailer for this season
it's the lone wolf that has issues and
dies the pack survives together and you
can't just say that Arya and Sansa in
this pack you also can remember boom we
got a little brother brand who can see
and know everything so I think this
entire plan that Littlefinger has which
by the way would be so annoying to me if
it actually was effective and like
messed up the hierarchy of the north and
Starks I think it's all going to blow up
in Littlefinger space I think that he's
betting against a family and that
happens to be the one family in Westeros
that does not turn on itself so I think
honestly I think this moment because
we're still late in the series is gonna
be Littlefinger's downfall because
honestly like he always got he's trying
to do these political games and that's
so over like unless he's gonna like
arrange a secret marriage between him
and the knight King like it's not his
political games aren't going to make
sense anymore they're not going to
matter so yeah what the hell prediction
Littlefinger will not make it out of
Winterfell live because of this nonsense
even if I did disagree with you I
wouldn't because I want him dead so bad
all right we've got another question
this one coming in from axe bubblegum
209 where in the world is Sam going
there is no way Gilly would want to go
back to the north and Sam
wouldn't want to go home so where's he
going so Winterfell hunt descent has to
be well it's not confirmed yes yet but
it is most likely he's sick of not being
believed every single time he tries to
reach out to people that can help him he
gets answered with a maybe probably not
stop being a weirdo so he wants to
become a man of action he took a bunch
of Scrolls which is a very very naughty
and hopefully they're filled with
information on how to tackle an undead
army and it's most likely he's going to
be heading north with them we have to
remember that the method of
communication is a lot like the method
of transport instantaneous so of course
he knows everything that's happened in
the letters of the Ravens including the
fact that bran and I are back in
Winterfell now the fact that John is
traveling that's two bits of information
that pretty much directs him to
Winterfell but a key piece of
information he doesn't know is the fact
that he's his dad and his brother Dickon
is now to dick off because they both
perished real bad two dragons
fire-breathing efforts the Mesa didn't
tell him said he would break his little
heart and he couldn't do it to him so he
could be walking back straight walking
it could be going straight back to
Winterfell on that cart and then
realized that if jon has teamed up with
Dany that he's essentially teamed up
with the woman that has destroyed his
family because she need to kill two
people to make a point and they were a
scapegoat we know what dragons like to
do to go haha
iam stop trying to be funny what's your
whole point to build up to that phone
yep okay good good good
we know that's for good Game of Thrones
fun hey we got the question good this
one is from Khurshid Dali two eight nine
how in the seven hells to jour and for
us know each other
Philip you've got the answer for this
one yeah the show just kind of like
threw it in there with the rest of my
girl the people will figure it out
no Jorah knows Thoros from the siege of
Pyke which was part of the Greyjoy
rebellion that was the same thing that
resulted in beyond being given over his
award to the storks it's our buddy hold
Balin Greyjoy was rebelling as you do
and it actually has if it's kind of a
shame we didn't see it because it
actually has some of our favorite
characters with their like it's not just
Jorah and Thoros there was also Jamie
Lannister was there and Ned Stark was
there obviously that's how he gets
beyond but we didn't ever get to see it
because before the show started though
there was a clip that I remembered and I
found out loaded up here
of Barristan Selmy and Jorah talking
about this moment when they first
started going to Pyke about who like got
into the castle first and that's where
you see that Jorah actually knows Thoros
in check it out it was a [ __ ] of a
scene hmm you were first through the
breach at Pyke
the second course Amir went in alone
waving that flaming sword of his there
bloody madman Robert knighted you after
the battle and then he tells a story
about how he really needs to pee when he
was knighted yeah but here's what I
actually think is interesting the
version of Thoreau's are describing is
so amazing it's such a good fighter and
he's the one that wield fire sword right
please let us see that next week he
sounds awesome what you don't like
bolding men bun dude sits in the corner
and I only say that because the Hound
made a comment on it as well [ __ ]
Batman buns I just wanted to be amazing
please be amazing next episode hey we
saw it in the trailer that he's going to
wield that sword again mom red even
though don't you dare yeah what I think
somebody else yeah okay alright no
where's all Berek Berek okay we'll have
this conversation later what to uncover
let's move on to the Power Rankings now
this is a part of the show where you
guys decide for us who is the most
influential and badass character of that
particular episode I'm very excited cuz
because I'm again a data nerd you guys
have heard that before and I love when
the data kind of splits an interesting
way and it's always been pretty obvious
who kind of had the power who won that
week so there's been some surprises in
the other parts but usually it's been a
lot of vote for the main one this one
was really really close yeah that's got
our alright number three my
least favorite character because he's
such a brilliant actor and he does creep
so well it's Littlefinger now he's got
seventeen point nine percent of your
vote so he's obviously they're
manipulating Winterfell and he's doing
bidding on behalf of Sansa which I'm not
a fan of because we know that Sansa
doesn't like him yet it's working and he
managed to fool aya now after last
episode where she defeated Brienne
physically she hasn't quite caught up
mentally and that's where Peter is
stepping in and kind of like leading her
down the rabbit hole right and then her
through her Sansa through Sansa the
Starks to the starts the north like I do
get definitely this amount of power is
kind of how he's always functioned I
just don't think it's going to last very
long I think is the cross coming in at
position number two Daenerys Targaryen
with eighteen percent that's very close
now she's obviously got the upper hand
in the war against Sophie Fernau so much
so though that associ is interested in
taking the Armistice for potential maybe
a fake one but yeah she definitely has
puts there Cena plays works like she's a
threat Jaime's even saying it three
dragons I've seen it in action we are in
trouble right well and even the the
initial Aegon conquest like that didn't
need much time to convince people like
oh he's got tiny army and three dragons
we're done yeah so that kind of like
wraps up really quickly when people
experience dragons in battle the same
thing kind of happened here where I was
just like oh we're done yeah it's kind
of great to see Danny back on that list
though because it was so few for a hot
minute they're coming in at number one
though Jon Snow aka John Targaryen at
33.2% he's obviously convinced two major
power players
to put a pause on the wall for the Seven
Kingdoms to focus on his dead people
problem that's happening in the north
now that is a hard thing to do because
they don't believe him yet they're going
to put the weapons down stop bickering
down in the south and actually focus on
the real threat kind of cool yeah it is
cool my issue with him being number one
well I think he does deserve it if he's
ever gonna be number one it was like
gonna be this time but like I love John
he's my man like he like angry
he's my Gendry if you will he unites
people that's all Johnny Snow
uh general dr. Horrible's reference but
I think people are under estimating how
tenuous his control over the north is
like the moment he's gone
they're totally ready to rebel against
him and then just because Santa isn't
like awful he doesn't lose the entirety
of the north so that's probably why you
didn't even like blow anyone else
completely out of the water in the
rankings this week like in the other two
were apart by just 0.1 percent don't you
trashed the dragon you just the dragon
yeah yeah so on the other hand he
touched a dragon like a puppy like a
good boy so he's a complete jerk on yes
yeah well I think it's interesting as
well to note that there was just a 0.1%
difference between our third and second
place as well between Littlefinger and
Danny come on can we just get rid of
Linga little fingers I think that would
actually be more satisfying to me at
this point than getting rid of Cersei
who said oh yeah I like this like him
that much I think he's going down with
us like as much do you do but model
attended a cookout alrighty so we had a
few deaths this episode the Game of
Thrones
we had Danny and drag on with a kill
count of two the tallies took him out
with a flame that was fun but also Genji
again he just makes you nervous
dangerous I know every gender he's back
and he's wielding a big old hammer which
is symbolic in itself but the fact that
he uses it in his rage and not even do
sighs even though he's a smithy he could
have a choose your sword is like no I've
got my hammer and the Davis was like are
you ready yes I am ready to go and it's
so cool and then it means telling when
he's need it's like pow pow face is gone
like melons exploding behind me anyway I
think it's kind of rude that you don't
impress the Gendry is the same cool Ken
as a dragon and Jenny those or whatever
it's impressive
Tim Gendry I think this gravity all I'm
sure the show what do you mean I've
already treated tired you to you today I
knew it I sensed it stop hematite oh you
said stop hammer time to the actor let
me wallow in my pity and shame I'm sorry
after time hey anyway there's another
episode coming next week let's have a
look at the teaser shall we yeah well
you get hammered
he was in skiing we'll watch these
aren't predictions on the other side
death is the enemy the first enemy and
the last
[Music]
the enemy always wins
i'ma still need to fighting
I'm scared Archie what do you scatter
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
holding in a [ __ ] at all times yeah and
I [ __ ] Who am I Who am I ready Maude
thirty minutes before we went on camera
no the ninth king I think it's time for
our prediction yeah let's have a chat
about what we thinks gonna happen next
episode uh if you know there was only
one location there was only one thing
happening or not yeah so I'm thinking
we're going to get our hardhome 2.0 and
just pretty much focus the entire
episode on the events taking place above
the wall because we haven't really seen
much we've only seen what's happened to
the Ravens eyes by a brand other vision
that happened in the fire we don't know
what's going up there going on I'm super
down for hardhome 2.0 that's my bull and
Miguel splash Nick directed hardhome and
he's one of the best directors he's not
directed it even keep directing next
season but hardhome was one of the best
episodes ever if this is anything like
hardhome which i think i agree i think
it actually probably will be I think
we'll get some like cold fights with
White Walkers then I'm already like
signed up for like best episode probably
of the season but I'm gonna go one
further for my prediction I'm gonna
guess that there's no way all of our
magnificent seven kind of dudes are
going to make it out of our way as soon
as you see the walkout and it was mold
on the seven it's like well you're gonna
die you're gonna die I don't think it's
just going to be red shirts like an
extra fish for people I think that at
least one of our main seven is going to
die and if I had to pick even though
it's just saying I can't wait for him to
be all amazing I'm gonna have to say
it's gonna be my man Thoreau's because
like I said I do want to see him be a
badass but if he is well then there goes
all his story potential he's a badass
but also the moment he dies there goes
any potential resurrecting for beric
Dondarrion gonna say right sorry answer
[ __ ] finally would get real for Berek
and kind of for Johnny man I said don't
bring me back but if you don't have a
red priest up there nobody's going back
where is that red priests oh she's over
doing something else well him blue but
also but so there there's no red
briefing area they're gonna die and stay
dead that's my guess
how are they going to burn the bodies
quickly if they have to make an escape
they're going to be resurrected oh my
god we're going to see cirrhosis or what
potentially maybe I'd be real bummed but
I can't wait for next week's episode and
that is a great reason for us to
dedicate next week's end
in artwork to these guys so send off
your art of the amazing seven heroes
looking badass teaming up you can do use
any movie as like a ref yeah you can do
magnificent seven which they said was a
reference but also the Avengers Suicide
Squad Justice League there's so many of
these whatever you want
let's see them as the epic badasses that
this team is before they get all along
injury by default with the hammer yeah
injury would be in there by the way
please if you could do 16 by 9 aspect
ratio so we can fill up the entire
screen that would be helpful thank you
so much hey speaking of filling the
screen this week watch until the end of
the video and you'll see more of what I
was talking about that's right madman
ginjury and his big ol arms in his
effort route 10 one of them has a bead
which is what I wanted he look great I
actually saw another one he's got huge
ol nipples he's a big boy I was going to
say I have a beard but I don't have I
don't have those nipples mmm it's my
pull yourself together woman hi any any
way if you want to reach out to me at
Maude Garrett and you can check out geek
balm on YouTube to give that a subscribe
I'm at female you can hit me up on
Twitter and I'll chat with you about
Game of Thrones thanks guys yeah
thirteen for two things and more artwork
bye bye bye